let's
let's make some predictions he can be
wrong about good
what major political people are you
thinking will run in 2024 including
trump
junior senior or ivanka
i don't know any trump
trump uh and
uh who do you think wins i think joe
biden
will run again in 2024 and i think he
will run against someone with the last
name trump
i do not know whether that is trump or
trump jr
uh but i think one of those people will
probably be the gop nominee in 2024. who
is it
some prominent political figure was it
romney somebody like that
said that trump will win the primary if
he runs again of course
that's not even a question trump is the
single most popular figure
in the republican party by orders of
magnitude
oh i mean probably more honestly there
was a actually i can tell you because i
saw the data
which is that pre-january 6th it was
like 54
of republicans wanted him to run again
then it went down
eight points after january 6 2 days
later
and then after impeachment it went right
back up to 54
so the exact same number is in
february at post impeachment vote as it
was after
november now look yeah again surveys
etc but like
that's all the data we have that's what
i can point to if trump runs he
will be the nominee and he will be he
will be the 2024 nominee
i just don't know if he wants to it it
really depends like
do you think he wins after the trump
vaccine
heals all of us do you think trump wins
it depends on how popular culture
functions over the next four years and i
can tell you that they are
because i don't think biden has that
much to do with it because again
trump is not a manifestation of an
affirmative policy action
it is a defensive bulwark wall
against cultural liberalism uh at its
best
so it's like this is why it doesn't
matter what biden does
if there are more riots if there is
a more sense of persecution amongst
people who are more lean towards
conservative or like hey
i don't know about that that's crazy
then he
very well could win let's okay let's say
joe biden doesn't run and they put up
like kamala harris i think he would i
think he would beat her
and i i don't think there's a question
that trump would beat kamala harris in
2024.
and you don't think anybody else i don't
know how the the process works you don't
think anybody else on the democratic
side can uh
take the well how could you run against
the sitting vice president
you know it's like if joe joe biden has
a 98 approval rating
in the democratic party if he says she
is my heir
i think enough people will listen to him
in a competitive primary
or a non-competitive primary and then
there's all these things about how
primary systems themselves are rigged
the dnc could make it known
that they'll blacklist anybody who does
try and primary kamala harris
um and look i mean progressives aren't
necessarily all that popular
amongst actual democrats like we found
that out um
during the election there's an entire
constituency which loves joe biden and
joe biden level politics
and so if he tells them to vote for
kamala i think i think she would
probably get it
but again there's a lot of game theory
obviously happening but see
i think you're talking about everything
you're saying is
correct about mediocre candidates it
feels like
if there's somebody like a really strong
i don't want to use this term
incorrectly but populist
somebody that speaks to the the 80
that's
is able to provide bold
eloquently described solutions that are
popular
i think that breaks through all of this
nonsense how how do they break through
the primary system because the problem
is
the primary system is not populism it's
primaries so it's like but you don't
think they can tweet
their way to well you have to be willing
to win a gop
primary you basically have to be at
whoever wins the gop primary
in my opinion will be the person most
hated by the left one of the people
things that people forget is you know
who came in second to trump
ted cruz and the reason why is because
ted cruz was the second most hated guy
by liberals in america a second to trump
they have nothing in policy in common
but don't you
think this kind of brilliantly described
system of
hate being the the the main mechanism
of our electoral choices yeah don't you
think that just has to do with mediocre
candidates
like it like it's
basically the field of candidates
including trump including everybody
was just like didn't make anyone feel
great
right it's like really this is what we
have to choose from
maybe a mark cuban or like
uh mark cuban as a democrat or
it would have to be somebody like that
somebody who because here's the thing
about trump it's not just that it was
trump he was so
famous like people don't realize
he was so
famous like i even when i first met
trump i met
a couple of other presidents but when i
met trump even i felt like
kind of starstruck cause i was like yo
this is the guy from the apprentice
yeah i'm like this is the dude like yeah
like cause i'm like my dad and i used to
sit and watch the apprentice when i was
in high school and then
one of the guys was from college station
where i grew up and were like oh my god
like
that guy's on the apprentice like it was
a phenomenon there's like that level
it's kind of like when i met joe rogan
i'm like holy that's a good joke
that's i don't feel that way when i meet
mitt romney or tom cotton or josh hall i
met all of them um but there's a lot of
celebrities right do you think there's
some celebrities we're not even thinking
about that could step in
the rock so i i was about to say i think
the rock could do it but
does he want to do it i mean it's
terrible like it's terrible gig
it's very hard to do i don't know if the
rock necessarily has like
the formed policy agenda because then
here's the other problem what what if we
set
ourselves up for a system where like
these people keep winning but like with
trump they have no idea how to run a
government
it's actually really hard right and you
have to have the know-how and the trust
to find the right people this is this is
where the genius
element comes in is you have to
understand that front
and you have to understand how to
execute discrete tasks like
this is the fdr this is why it's so hard
like
fdr lincoln tr they were who they were
and they live in history and their name
rings like for a reason
you